you had another point as it relates to
another team we were talking about
trying to pay their players and i'm
going to let you tee up the point that
you made as it relates to how the dallas
cowboys are going to pay all their guys
and what one specific guy who needs to
be paid by the cowboys should consider
doing well that's right i mean we're
talking about the running back ezekiel
elliott right i mean first of all you
and i discussed many a times over the
last year as long as we've known each
other now how brutal the running back
position is the how brutal the market is
at times but you're talking about a
position where it's just car crash after
car crash after car crash and especially
when you talk about a a running back
that has the style of of uh play that
ezekiel elliott has he is a car crash
runner he's either going to run you over
or just run by you with his speed but
yes i made the point that uh we were
talking about the cowboys ezekiel
elliott should ask for money right now
he should ask for a new contract and not
play another minute uh he's going into
year four of his career he's
eligible for a new contract he's led the
the nfl in rushing two out of the first
three years of his career he's led the
nfl in rushing attempts two out of the
first three years of his career probably
would be three for three if he didn't
have to deal with some of the suspension
stuff that dated back to ohio state in
year two that affected things there but
you made the point you know you said
well gosh ezekiel elliott it seems like
they're just going to run him into the
ground and then get rid of him when he's
done well that's why ezekiel needs to
just draw the line in the sand right now
pay me todd gurley money or better i've
led the football in rushing two years
and you know two out of three years and
i'm not going to let you hear and just
absolutely abuse my body before i get to
re-up with a new contract and not really
capitalize off of his god-given gifts
which are his legs his butt and his
ability to run the ball between the
tackles
yeah when you look at what they did with
demarco murray in the final year of his
rookie contract did 1845 rushing yards
led the league and set a cowboys
single-season franchise rushing record
that still stands ezekiel hasn't beaten
that number and they let demarco murray
leave in free agency no franchise tag no
competitive offer to keep him they
waited a year they drafted ezekiel
elliott and i could see them doing the
same thing with elliot chew him up spit
him out move on to another running back
because we've seen so many of these
second contracts because of the timing
after four or five years the guy has had
his best seasons you're giving him all
this money and then the decline begins
yeah the seahawks couldn't wait to get
rid of sean alexander one year after
they gave him a contract that came one
year after he was the nfl mvp todd
gurley arthritic condition in his knee
the rams surely regret the deal that
they gave him last year so if you're
ezekiel elliott it's incumbent on you
while you are still performing at a high
level to say i want mine it worked for
emmitt smith in 1993 and here's why it's
going to work now if he does it jerry
jones is desperate to put a super bowl
team together and the last thing he
wants is a repeat of
his star running back checking out for
the first two weeks of the season like
evan smith did now no doubt maybe he
wants that maybe he wants that because
that season ended in the super bowl win
maybe he'll think that's an ingredient
into making it happen i wouldn't i
wouldn't tempt that if i were jerry
jones i would get the guy happy and get
the guy paid and when all these other
names demarcus lawrence amari cooper dak
prescott byron jones they're paying this
guy this guy this guy this guy and and
ezekiel elliott yeah no real talk about
extending him because they may very well
be thinking about the five years of his
rookie contract exactly plus one more
year under the franchise tag after six
years hey we're gonna let you hit the
open market we respect you so much zeke
we're gonna let you hit the open market
yeah good luck finding an offer because
we ain't giving you yeah that's right
good hit hit the open market i mean
you've only ran the ball 2 000 times in
the last six years and only just been
you know crushed by fletcher cox 100
times and you know bobby wagners of the
world and jamal adams of the world
whoever it may be i mean that's where
it's not fair to the running backs and
again you and i talk about the tools
that are available to players uh yes
star players have a few more tools uh
you know you know at their availability
than maybe other players do and this is
certainly a situation yeah ezekiel is a
star he's the go-to guy for that dallas
cowboys offense the way they play
football in general is all formulated
around the run game and ezekiel
elliott's ability to constantly push the
pile keep them in good situations and
then then he's gonna break one or break
some tackles whatever it may be but they
play ball control type of football and
ezekiel elliott plays it in a physical
manner and i think this is one of those
this one of those situations where hey
ezekiel you're a stud you're a star
you're arguably the best running back in
football and the dallas cowboys really
need you you have the power here right
now in this situation and if you wanted
to ask for more money i think sims and
florio would back you up and say go
ahead big guy cash in while you can
because uh we don't know how many years
of plan you're going to have at a real
quality high level
yeah i don't know that you want to rely
on the advice from the two of us is the
thing that you you know hang your hat on
before you make a major career move but
we still would have i think we're spot
on on this one it's it's our guts his
blood basically yeah in this situation
but but this this highlights one of the
problems with the current labor deal the
rookie wage scale that was put in place
in 2011 with an eye toward ensuring that
busts don't take all these millions out
of the system to go to other players as
part of that and i remember talking to
the commissioner about this face-to-face
in 2010
what does the league propose to do
to reward the guys who aren't busts
because you're taking money away from
the guys who never earn it but you're
also never giving it to the guys who do
earn it the guys who did deserve it and
eliot clearly deserved the windfall and
it's not a windfall because you earned
those dollars he should have gotten the
kind of contract that pre-2011 the
fourth overall pick in the draft
received so
how do we build into the next cba
protections for the young players who
are good and it's in the interest of all
players that this happened because the
more that these good young players make
more money the market gets pushed up and
there's more pressure out there that
other players can put on teams to pay
them because they can say this is how
much this guy makes this is how much
that guy makes these young players who
come in and make a difference need to be
making more money that's something if
the if the union is looking for
realistic things to push for next time
around that's something realistic and
that's something beneficial and if
ezekiel elliott isn't going to have that
baked into the cba then he needs to go
out there and take advantage of all
avenues to try to get a new contract now
instead of letting the cowboys use him
up and put him in a point where he's got
nothing left when it's time for him to
become a free agent yeah no no doubt i
think you know you make some good points
too about yeah those guys that do
outperform those rookie contracts guys
that are you know let's you know in the
middle of the first round late first
round um yeah i mean i i think what we
want to see from them is okay if you're
a receiver who gets picked at number 22
on the draft right he's the 22nd pick of
the draft he has an amazing year where
he's in in stats he's top five in all
categories top five in receptions top
five in yards i would love to see him
yeah let's make more than the four or
five million dollars maybe the nfl can
find some way to go okay uh because of
what you did in your performance on the
field you get some sort of sort of
performance award where you get paid
like you're one of the five best
receivers in football now that you reach
that plateau on your rookie contract
things like that that go through my mind
i'm always looking for ways that the
players can capitalize more on their
talents this is their one shot this is
all they got they're not doctors they're
not going to be able to do this till
they're 70 years old football players
have between the age of 21 and 30
basically to strike it rich or really
capitalize on the god-given best talent
they have to put forward and they have
to take advantage of it when the and
strike when the iron's hot i mean think
of it this way when it is dramatically
better to be the first pick in round two
than the last pick it makes no sense
exactly it makes no sense it makes no
sense and the problem is the players are
so brainwashed to think it's an honor to
be a first-round pick they'd rather be a
first-round pick than a second-round
pick because that's so baked into our
culture as it relates to to the nfl that
oh hey i want to be a first round pick
no it's far better to be a second round
pick than to be the last pick in round
one darius if you're the last pick in
round one you're tied up for five years
no doubt and who are the rookies we had
rookies on the all pro team this week
this year like derwyn james right
derwent james is the perfect example
there he was right a middle draft pick
he's already one of the three or four
best safeties in football like would
love to see some way where they can make
him capitalize on going you know what
you play a position that's really brutal
physical you got to hit linebackers and
i mean running backs and pulling guards
and okay you know you're obviously one
of the best of your position already
like to see them you know bear the
fruits of their labor there and be
rewarded for what they do
and when i asked the commissioner how
are you going to take care of this how
are the teams going to take care of this
to ensure that the players who
have performed at a high level get the
money they should have gotten he said
well the teams will take care of that
well they don't no they look at it look
at the texans in jadavian clowning right
he's put in his five years and now he's
got another year under the franchise tag
why because they're exploring the
possibility of chewing him up and
spitting it out and moving on when he
has nothing left that's exactly what's
gonna happen potentially to ezekiel
elliott and here one of the problems is
in this last cba they changed the
the trigger for negotiating a new
contract from two years to three years
so why not just go back to two years let
teams do a new car let a guy begin
holding out after two years you hold on
after two years in a damn thing your
team can do you hold on after three
years they can pay you why not make it
two years and then allow an ezekiel
elliot or someone else who has a great
first two years of his career to say hey
you know what i'm not a bust pay me what
i should have made coming out yeah of
the draft right anyway we're not going
to solve all the problems here we're
just throwing some ideas out to the
extent that the players are looking for
things they can really sink their teeth
into these you know the players want to
get rid of the franchise tag it's not
going away these things i think are more
practical to try to get the league's
attention and these are things that just
as a matter of basic fairness need to be
taken care of that's right these players
do get chewed up they get spat out and
they never make the money they should
have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports